foreign
[Music]
would you like crawl here bro is he mad
well you're getting urge you're getting
murdered no no no let me guess
your alarm clock didn't go off oh look
your dog ate your alarm clock your alarm
clock ate your keys your keys
grandmother died and they need a
personal date oh there's none of those
things what was it this time Barry it
was um something else that was far less
outlandish and I know I missed the
meeting but I'd still really like to to
present these case files for potential
review I think we rushed these cases
we got a backlog six months deep and you
want us to move slower you need to focus
your motion do the work close the case
move on
you have a lot of potential Barry you
shouldn't still be getting coffee after
all these years
you're right that's that's true go get
me a coffee
Two Sugars oh yeah
you're gonna love this
the Johnson case the evidence our lab
analyzed was more than sufficient to be
conclusive it's still working that
evidence diligence
Barry was still working on that evidence
thank you for up to you and we'd still
be scraping Ted Bundy's molars you know
what I'm so happy you find this all so
hilarious but we are dealing with real
people's lives people's families and I
don't think you can grasp the gravity of
that so why don't you leave me alone
Barry Allen
Iris West you know my full name also yes
from school uh where are you tell us you
had a friend from school we actually
didn't know that Barry had a friend yeah
what does that make it now
one one
you guys so
um bye you guys
um
they're not really my friends they're my
work friends so you work here
I feel like we saw each other like a few
years ago right no because we haven't
seen each other since
College yeah
maybe I was just thinking about you
well I'm really glad I ran into you yeah
yeah
your father's appeal is tomorrow right
yeah how
sorry how do you know about that I'm
covering it for the paper
oh how is he holding up
um
are you asking for the paper no I'm
asking as a friend oh although I'm sure
the public would want to know as well
well my my only official comment is that
my dad is innocent right
I mean no one
would want to believe that their father
killed their mother what do you mean
believe my dad shouldn't be in jail my
mom should be alive it's not about what
I believe it's about what the truth is
right no yes that's
oh my God that's what I meant
right
sorry I have no official comment at this
time
[Music]
you have any collect calls from the iron
Heights Penitentiary do you wish to
accept yes
I'm fine
I ran into an old college friend Iris
West today didn't you have a monster
crush on her
Dad I am
I had a friend run the old security
camera footage from the store through
this new program he's developed and it's
Crystal Clear now
it's just
you never look up Dad
you can't see your face
I started thinking about the next appeal
you need to stop worrying about your old
man
dad I don't want you've done this before
this was a last-ditch effort and we'll
go through the motions tomorrow
you know sometimes I even think it's
probably easier for me to be in
up there
without her
is this the way I can imagine she's
alive
out there living her life
all right
you there
yeah I'm here Dad
hey remember that sauce you make on
Sundays
no wow smell like basil tomato
es what was that song
remember that part
it's not fair well it's not fair monkey
this question is stupid how many
calculations can you think of with an
answer of 24. there are bajillion
answers how am I supposed to fit them
all you are right they're out of agility
and answers to this question not every
problem has a solution sometimes you
just have to let go
keep your brain a rest and hold me make
the pasta come on
they need you to do me a favor are there
any favors okay very easy to do in my
favor oh very yeah anything
I need another can of tomatoes
you have a can of tomatoes I need
another one I thought you guys went to
the store this morning
but I forgot the tomatoes
this looks way more fun let's just let
Barry go to the store you drive right
squirm what you're getting so big you
can do anything look at you you're
getting gray actually no the blue one
okay got it blue can not the green one
right no worm can not the blue one
you can start singing
[Music]
I love you monkey I love you more
Harry
this is
Barry Barry call 9-1-1 now
Mary
don't worry about tomorrow
we always knew it was a long
Beach dad
your call with iron Heights Penitentiary
has been terminated
thank you
[Music]
foreign